[Music]
all right we're back on overtime
questions for the panel Kent Kristin
Psaltis do you think the rise of the
internet and social media is the reason
why there are fewer young Republicans I
don't think so I actually think that the
rise of social media gives Republicans a
good opportunity to try to get their
message out to young voters if you're
just relying for instance on TV ads a
lot of young people aren't necessarily
watching you know the network broadcast
news I'm sure they're watching this
program but they're not necessarily you
know that sort of traditional tactics
are it's tough to reach them so I really
think that first up for you know a
Republican group the internet gives you
a way to reach out to these folks and
try to win them over to your side
they're watching this program they're
not paying for it
that's stupid but you know I always
wonder because like polls mostly are
done through landlines right what
percentage go to like only 10% right go
to cell phones yeah so there are weird
regulations where it's tough to do what
who answers a landline old lonely people
and actually it probably isn't accurate
reflection cuz that too also goes to
vote yes young people don't vote well so
no young people do go well the one
characteristic that 11% in 2010 that's
in a midterm but in a presidential
election the number will go up well they
all count I mean it's only every two
years we're not asking a lot I know
there was a great rerun of scrubs that
night come on was it worth a tea bagger
Congress and I'm thinking okay is
American exceptionalism is is a
contributing factor to this selfishness
seen by the 1% no is American
exceptionalism a contributing factor to
the selfishness yeah I would say so
absolutely I mean I think part of what
we've lost in this country is something
that you talked about in terms of this
idea that you're supposed to give back
and you are your brother's keeper and we
do have an obligation and this idea of
and part of this idea of luck is you
know you get to be wealthy not by your
own steam but by the people who came
before you and as
with Warren would put point out you know
the people who pay for the roads that
move your goods so how about right
members of the 1% I mean you've got
folks like they're all giving you dates
you've got folks like Warren Buffett
you've got folks like Mark Zuckerberg
giving money to the Newark schools I
mean you've got it's worth remembering
the person who came up with the phrase
and the concept of American
exceptionalism a hundred years ago the
question what was American exception to
and it was an exception to the trend
that everywhere else where you had an in
that advanced industrial society you had
a major Socialist Party and that is that
is the thing the United States did not
have and that was the question why is
there no socialism in the United States
there were genes but in 1905 when this
essay was was written there was not and
no no that's what he was around he
didn't win but he that there's no that
was the question foreigner somber art
pose anyway I just got my essay but the
difference is the thing that has
happened over the past century is it
socialism has died everywhere that there
are no European part European countries
like the United States have a party that
is to the right of center that is to the
left of center and they're both
market-based pot country's parties
arguing over the size some basis of our
nationalism that we will have more
inequality than any other advanced
industrial country we have Wiest the
least equality of opportunity of any
country the ratio of CEO pay to that of
ordinary workers is the highest without
any and corresponding productivity
differential so there are some ways in
which we are exception and we are excuse
me
I know what they're talking about - we
are already like every major modern
country a quasi socialist country in
fact the 1928 Socialist Party platform
has been completely adopted by this
country we have Medicare we have Social
Security when it is this our American
politics look more like other people's
politics than they did in the days of
mass socialist parties in Europe and the
absence of mass socialist parties in the
United States and so one of the things
that is that is healthy about that one
things Americans should learn from us
understand they have things to learn
from other countries America is it that
the advanced industrial countries look
more and more there are these cultural
differences there are these institutions
there are cultural differences but I
don't think you know there are studies
that I've been done of Americans and
asking what kind of distribution of
income do they think is right and what
they say is they'll pick out a
distribution of income it turns out the
one they like is Sweden they don't want
the distribution we have but they don't
understand the level of inequality that
we have the united states they've been
so to build goodies and i know if we get
obsessed with that with the 1% versus
the 99 there is a there are a lot of
percentiles in the middle and who are
not necessarily selfish and and want to
be charitable and distribute to some of
the wealth but they're the ones who
maybe did work for it did not start with
the the handout and are basically saying
yeah we want to give back but we just
got it can we keep it for a while and I
think that middle ground a lot of people
who get forgotten in that I think
there's got to be a balance I mean one
of the things that's wonderful about
this country is as the president would
say his story is only possible in
America the you know his humble
beginnings as a mixed-race person at the
same at the same time I think it's true
but at the same time lecturing other
parts of the world about democracy when
our own democracy is kind of crumbling
around us so there's got to be a better
balance between what we do well in this
country and what we're trying to tell
others do as we say not as we do but
what matters is not you know the the
exceptions the stories and stories get
so much attention because they are so
unusual
it really matters is
what are the chances what are the
likelihood of somebody from the bottom
making it to the middle or the top and
in those terms in terms of Statistics we
do more poorly than any of the other
advanced countries and that's so
different from our self-image and and
what and what about Obama story could
not happen in other countries I mean we
haven't even elected a woman president
I mean Chile had a president who issues
a woman she was a socialist single
mother France we as elected people who
openly had affairs I mean this this this
is playing into that Republican
narrative only in America it's [ __ ]
it's not only in America other countries
allow things the same things we have I
think about that mark Rubio speech than
they made it CPAC last year we said this
is the only country in the world where
an idea that started out on a cocktail
napkin could wind up being traded on the
stock exchange know that they live there
seeing that the advanced industrial
countries face similar problems and they
face they face in a similarly acute
crisis right now and we are in this we
are in this together and a merit that
the idea that dates back a hundred years
the United States had a special did
visit didn't have monarchy and I didn't
have a feudal system we have we have
Americans of things to learn Americans
also have things to teach ok this is for
you
doctor stick you and Paul Krugman are
both winners of the Nobel Prize why are
your ideas dismissed in favor of budget
austerity that is projected to increase
rather than decrease deficits I don't
know I find them very very persuasive
you know and it's actually almost so
intuitive that the problem right now is
there's not enough demand the problem
right now is the reason companies aren't
investing is not that they don't have
cash they're sitting on a pile of cash
they leased to larger companies
there's nobody demanding their goods if
you now take away demand the economy is
going to get weaker you know it's that
simple and yeah there's one party that
doesn't seem
understand that you know you look like a
younger male Brooke I feel like you
could have got switched at birth out of
time [ __ ] I love this panel but we got
to go okay
thank you folks Real Time with Bill
Maher ask bill and its guests your
questions right after the show at
hbo.com